reportage, vous pouvez
contester.
♪ ♪ ♪
- La mauvaise nouvelle est
arrivée dans leur boîte
aux lettres : la valeur
du duplex de Laurence Harvey
et Philippe Beaudin,
dans Hochelaga-Maisonneuve,
a grimpé de près de 200 000..
PHILIPPE BEAUDIN, propriétaire
- Et maintenant, c'est évalué
à 604 400 $. C'est une
augmentation de 40...
- 47 %, je pense.
- Oui, c'esta.a.
- Les taxes municipales
sont calculées en fonction
de la valeur des propriétés,
qui est révisée tous les trois
ans. La Ville de Montréal
vient de compléter l'exercice.
Pour le rôle foncier 2023-20
la hausse est de 35 %,
en moyenne, dans le secteur
résidentiel. La date
de référence utilisée
pour les calculs est
le 1er juillet 2021 :
le marché immobilier était
alors en pleine ébullition.
DOMINIQUE OLLIVIER, présidente,
Comité exécutif, Ville de MTL
- On fait deux choses
pour s'assurer qu'il y a pas
de trop gros choc financier
pour les citoyens et les
citoyennes. D'abord, on étale
le rôle sur trois ans,
donc ce qui permet d'avoir
une hausse qui est graduelle.
Et la deuxième chose qu'on fait,
c'est qu'on descen t t taux
de taxes.
- Au final, ce sont
les propriétaires qui ont vu
la valeur de leur résidence
augmenter davantage que
la moyenne, comme Laurence
et Philippe, qui verront
leur compte de taxes grimper
le plus. Dans leur cas,
la dernière facture s'élevait
à 3400 $.
- Je m'attends à 500 $ par année
d'augmentation de taxes.
- C'est une dépense
supplémentaire qui s'ajoute
à tout le reste.
LAURENCE HARVEY, propriétaire
- On a mis vraiment tout
ce qu'on avait pour acheter,
pour ne pltrtrtrtre locataires,
pour devenir propriétaires.
Comme je te dis, 40 à 45 %
de notre budget y passe,
ce qui est quand même plus élevé
que ce qui est recommandé, là.
T'sais, cette augmentation-là
va amener des décisions :
moins de sorties, c'est sûr,
moins de resto.
- Pour établir la valeur
des propriétés, la Ville examine
environ 25 000 transactions
immobilières par année.
C'est donc le prixeeeee
de ces immeubles qui sert
à déterminer la valeur
de tous les autres.
Me SYLVAIN BÉLAIR,ocococococat l
- Le service d'évaluation dégage
des indices de variation
des valeurs par type d'immeuble,
résidentiel, commercial,
industriel, et par localité.
- Mais ce processus d'évaluation
de masse n'est pas sans faille :
il ne tient pas compte des
particularités qui pourraient
faire baisser la valeur
d'une résidence.
- Des infiltrations d'eau,
problèmes de toiture, problèmes
de fondations, ou encore des cas
où il y a eu un entretien
négligé de la propriété,
et dans l'éventualité
où on voudrait la mettre
en vente, par exemple,
on se dirait : Bien,
on a des travaux à faire.
- Les propriétaires qui
s'estiment lésés peuvent
contester leur évaluation
foncière.
En 2017, ils sont plus
de 2700 à l'avoir fait
et 56 % d'entre eux ont obtenuee
de la valeur de leur propriété.
En 2020, c'était 46 %.
Bref, le jeu peut en valoir
la chandelle.
PIERRE PAGÉ, Montréal pour tous
- Le système a été fait
sur la base de "je visite
votre maison aux neuf ans".
Mais là, ça ne visite plus!
Alors, si l'évaluateur, il peut
pas venir, ça fausse u
le portrait d'ensemble,
puis ça induit des erreurs
qui font qu'il y a plus de gens
insatisfaits.
- Avec son galalalalalalal
pour tous, Pierre Pagé aide
les citoyens qui veulent
contester leur évaluation.
La démarche coûte 75 $ pour ceux
qui ont un immeuble qui vaut
500 000 $ et moins. C'est 300 $
pour les propriétés qui vale
entre un demi et deux millions.
- J'ai payé moins que 20 000 $
pour ma maison.
- Albanie Morin a fait
l'exercice deux fois
par le passé et obtenu
gain de cause. En 2014,
la Ville a réduit la valeur
de son duplex du Plateau-Mont-
Royal de près de 114 000 $
et de 37 000 $ trois ans
plus tard.
ALBANIE MORIN, propriétaire
- J'avais pas fait
de rénovations depuis 89.
Alors, me comparer à des maisons
où on a fait des rénovations
récentes au coût d'aujourd'hui,
me mettre au même niveau,
ça tient pas, là.
- Ces baisses de valeur lui ont
fait épargner des centaines,
voire des milliers de dollars
en taxes municipales.
- Je suis une personne
retraitée, j'ai... mes revenus
sont fixes.
- Elle ne sait pas encore
si elle contestera de nouveau
son évaluation cette année.
- Je peux faire tous
les préparatifs, demander
à la Ville de me donner
les comparables et voir
si ça vaut la peine.
C'est un exercice... il y a
de la préparation à faire.
- Chaque dollar compte et on a
beaucoup d'empathie pour ces
personnes-là. Mais il faut
se dire également qu'on reçoit
des services, on donne
des services, à la Ville,
pour cet argent-là, et nous
aussi, depuis des années,
on encaisse l'effet
de l'inflation.
- D'un côté, la Ville
de Montréal a besoin des revenus
de taxes pour avoir les moyens
de ses ambitions.
- Moi, je pourrais pas acheter
chez moi en ce moment.
Je pourrais pas acheter
la maison où on est.
- Mais de l'autre, bien des
résidents se demandent s'ils ont
les moyens d'être Montréalai